If we are given lemon juice and soap water
in two different beakers, will we be able
to list the difference between the two?
Perhaps the list will begin with different
colours, appearance and so on.
But these are just properties that we can see.
Are these the only differences?
There are more.
Lemon juice tastes very sour.
soap water tastes slightly bitter!
Please don’t try to taste it.
Just trust me, it tastes slightly bitter.
Is this a major difference between the two?
yes!
Taste is an important parameter, as it takes
us to the chemical properties.
Why does lemon juice taste sour?
And why does soap water taste bitter?
Any idea? the answer lies in their nature.
Lemon juice is an acid while soap is a base
do you know what an acid is and what a base is?
Lets get to know these terms first,
and later get into their details.
To begin with, we have acids.
The moment we hear the term “Acid”, something
scary, or something that would burn the surfaces,
is what pops up in our mind.
Well, that’s kind of true.
Because acids are known to create a burning
effect of whatever comes in contact with them.
They can erode the surfaces, or burn the skin
when they come in contact with it.
That’s how acids are!
The term “Acid” comes from the Latin word
“Acidus ” which simply means sour!
Yes!
So are all acids Sour to taste?
Yes they are!
The intensity of sourness may vary in different acids.
But the overall taste of acids is always sour.
The best examples of substances that contain acids
include citrus fruits like orange, lemon,
lime and grapes .
Now let’s talk about the soap water.
What nature does it have?
It is basic in nature.
which means soap is a base ! Or in other words, an
alkali
What do we mean by this?
For now all we need to know is that the mild,
bitter tasting compound is called a base.
Bases, when added to water, give foam, and
feel soapy when touched.
Bases are exactly opposite to acids.
The best examples of bases include baking
soda, washing soda, quick lime and many more.
This was about acids and bases in general.
Now can you tell me, what will happen if an
acid and an alkali – as in a base, come
together?
Will the solution explode?
Will it give an unexpected reaction?
Or something else?
Well, it is something that we already know.
Imagine, we mix a strong acid like Hydrochloric
acid with a strong base like sodium hydroxide
, what will be the result then?
the reaction yields sodium chloride and water
Sodium chloride is the common salt used
by us.
So, an acid with a base gives us salt and
water . this is a generalised reaction.
Salts are the products of reaction between
an acid and a base.
But now tell me one thing, how do we understand
whether a compound is acidic or basic?
Can we taste it every time?
If we are given a solution of concentrated
sulphuric acid, how are we supposed to know
it's nature?
Its not possible to bear even a drop of
it on your skin.
So tasting the solution is just out of thequestion.
So,now how do we say that this is an acidic solution?
There has to be a way to figure it out.
The solution has to undergo a few tests.
The substance used to check whether the compound
is acidic or basic is called an indicator
The indicators indicate by changing their colours!
Indicators when added with acids or bases,
show a change in colour.
That is how it becomes convenient for us to
find out whether the compound is acidic or
basic.
But what kind of substances are used as indicators?
Next, we will look at the various indicators .